esta vez tenemos la resta de una
expresión racional y otra expresión
racional y te encargo que pausa el vídeo
y veas que obtienes de resultado después
de hacer esta resta ok vamos a hacerlo
juntos y lo primero que quiero que notes
es que cuando restamos dos expresiones
racionales lo que necesitamos es un
mismo denominador y aquí claramente no
tenemos un mismo denominador así que
vamos a buscar un denominador común
recuerda un denominador común será aquel
que sea divisible por ambos
denominadores iniciales y al hacerlo
podamos multiplicar por una expresión
adecuada o un número adecuado que vamos
a obtener del denominador común ahora
bien el denominador común que se me
ocurre inmediatamente entre estas dos y
más porque estas expresiones no tienen
factor común es su producto así que voy
a decir que esto va a ser igual
y ahora voy a reescribir esta primera
expresión que tengo aquí la que voy a
poner de color anaranjado la voy a
escribir aquí tengo menos 5x de abajo
tengo 8 x + 7 pero ahora voy a
multiplicar tanto el numerador como el
denominador por 3 x 1 para que abajo me
quede el producto de los dos
denominadores así que voy a tomarme 8 x
+ 7 y voy a multiplicarlo por 3 x + 13 x
+ 1 este va a ser mi denominador común y
en la parte de arriba no lo puedo dejar
así necesito también multiplicar por 3 x
más uno para que se mantenga esta
expresión racional así que voy a
multiplicar también nuestro numerador
por 3x más
y observa sin / 3 x 1 / 3 x 1
simplemente me quedarían menos 5 x / 8 x
+ 7 que es mi expresión original lo
único que estoy haciendo es
multiplicando tanto arriba como abajo x
3 x 1 bien y a todo esto le vamos a
restar le vamos a restar esta parte de
aquí y tendríamos que hacer exactamente
lo mismo o bueno se me ocurre que
también hay otra forma de verlo también
podemos decir que a esto le vamos a
sumar le vamos a sumar el negativo de
este es decir le voy a cambiar el signo
voy a multiplicar por menos 1 esta
expresión y ahora en lugar de tomarme la
resta me voy a tomar la suma así que en
lugar de la resta voy a poner la suma de
quién y ahora éste es negativo ojo ten
cuidado porque si en el numerador tienes
más términos entonces tienes que
distribuir este signo negativo en cada
uno de esos términos multiplicar cada
uno
por -1 muy bien y voy a hacer lo mismo
abajo en el denominador voy a poner 8x +
7 que multiplica a 3 x + 1 muy bien este
es mi denominador común y en la parte de
arriba que me va a quedar bueno primero
tengo menos 6x kubica recuerda que le
cambia el signo para hacerlo un poco más
fácil entonces lo voy a poner aquí menos
6x cúbica y ahora observa lo siguiente
estoy multiplicando a 3 x 1 x 8 x 7 para
obtener mi denominador común
así que si multiplicó el denominador por
8 x + 7 también voy a multiplicar el
numerador por esa misma cantidad 8 x + 7
y de nuevo observa 8 x + 7 entre 8 x + 7
esto es 1 entonces si dividir a estos
dos llegarían a menos 6 x cúbica entre 3
x + 1 que es la expresión original
ya que tenemos un denominador común
vamos a resolverlo entonces esto va a
ser igual a quién y bueno en la parte de
abajo voy a poner mi denominador común
que es 8 x + 7 + 7 que multiplica a 3 x
+ 1 + 1 y bueno en la parte de arriba lo
primero que me va a quedar es esta parte
de color anaranjado que tengo aquí así
que vamos a distribuir este menos 5 x
que va a multiplicar a 3 x + 1 así que
primero voy a tener menos 5 x x 3 x y
bueno eso es lo mismo que menos 15 x
cuadrada y después tengo menos 5 x x 1
lo cual es menos 5 x muy bien y ahora a
esto le voy a sumar esta parte de color
verde y si te das cuenta aquí también
puedo distribuir este menos 6 x cúbica
primero que multipliquen
x y después que multipliquen a 7 y que
me va a quedar
bueno pues menos 6 x kubica por 8 x eso
es lo mismo que menos 48 x elevado a la
cuarta potencia y después tengo menos 6
x cúbica que multiplica 7 lo cual es
menos 42
x cúbica y ahora si observas todos estos
te vas a dar cuenta de que no podemos
reducir nada todos estos tienen un
exponente distinto cada uno de los
términos que forman el numerador tiene
una equis con un exponente distinto por
lo tanto no podemos reducir términos
semejantes así que tal vez estés tentado
a acomodar los términos y que esta parte
de arriba este numerador se vea de la
siguiente forma se vea como menos 48 x
cuarta vamos a empezar con el término
que tiene el exponente más alto y
después seguirían menos 42 x cúbica y
después menos 15 x cuadrada menos 15 x
cuadrada y por último menos 5x y bueno
claro todo esto está dividido por
nuestro denominador común que eran 8 x 7
8 x + 7 que multiplica a 3 x
+ 1 a 3 x + 1 y hemos acabado porque
observa nada de esto se puede factorizar
a este por ejemplo es divisible entre
seis pero éste es divisible entre 5 y
bueno este es divisible entre 5 pero no
entre 3 así que no se puede factorizar
nada de arriba y tampoco de acá abajo
así que es mejor dejarlo así y decir que
hemos terminado